all right guys
bang bang he's back jared what's up man
thanks for doing this again
what's up thanks paul great to be back
for sure
uh so for people who didn't listen to
the first time we did this
uh maybe give us kind of a quick two
minutes on your background and then
then you've got an update you're back at
the washington post so let's do it
yeah so we spoke um it was probably like
almost a year and a half two years ago
i was the ceo of poet which was a
decentralized
media technology every buzzword you
could think of company but really
focused on uh what blockchain can do for
news and media
which i'm still very very bullish on
happy to dive deep on that
and kind of talk through uh where poets
at but also
other companies and kind of what they're
focusing on there but really trying to
get to the bottom of
uh a thing that i'm still hyper focused
on which is like what's the value of
content
right we're in these creator-led
societies uh our attention is constantly
being given to all these different
platforms where creators are producing
but like what is that value and what are
the business models built around that
value
uh so yeah the last time we spoke i was
ceo
poet i left and returned to the
washington post
where i oversee the entire commercial
business so really focused on
how we make money at the post how we
drive all of our revenue arms
subscriptions
advertising i oversee r d so what new
businesses
products technologies we could build um
which we could then create new
businesses out of which we've done twice
uh one is called art publishing which is
a software as a service arm for
content creators and content management
systems that we license to now like 1300
sites globally
and the second and most recent is zeus
technology which is kind of the revenue
side of that framework so really trying
to think about how
media companies particularly news
journalism media companies
can compete with the behemoths like
facebook and google
when it comes to revenue and how we can
build software that they can license tie
themselves together and kind of
bring on a more sustainable approach to
you know their their
business yeah and i think part of what
is so
uh interesting and i love following you
on twitter because you just
it's obvious or constantly thinking
about this and um
you just nailed a key piece which is
you're not just thinking about it from
the content right like what are creators
going to do next what platforms are they
going to
and all that you're also thinking about
how do these platforms make money
whether they're the facebooks and the
googles and twitters of the world all
the way down to
the actual media companies and then even
further down to the content creators
themselves and kind of full stack like
how does money flow and where does value
accrue
uh in reading all the things you've been
putting out there's two key themes that
you've been talking about
uh i think the first one and only
because you wrote about it first so
we'll start there
which is uh media companies are going to
become similar to
um these music labels and so maybe talk
a little bit about like
what does that mean and kind of
elaborate in what you wrote on
yeah it's really it's really interesting
to think about um
all the complexities in kind of the
content creation world and the media
world that seems
so so so like like like
i guess the term is complex like it
seems like there's so much going on
all these different roles all these
different companies doing all these
different things and
and when you really kind of back up and
boil it down it ends up being very
simple right and and
um i started kind of diving into this
notion that what is the role of a media
company right i think
roles of media companies at least
decades ago when everything was owned by
that media company
was a lot right they own the
distribution they own the relationship
with the customers
uh they literally own the value of their
product like an
advertiser would call in the 80s you
know the
person leading revenue at cbs and say
hey how much for a 30-second spot and
they'd basically like make up a number
and they'd be like all right we're in
right there was like
no kind of free market to then kind of
set what the costs and structures would
be and media companies
had a lot of power right revenue power
relationship power
distribution power um and of course they
were like the medium that people were
getting information there weren't all
these options
and uh everyone knows what happened when
the platforms kind of came about but um
all that
somewhat became very distributed and now
we're entering into worlds of like
things being decentralized but that
gatekeeper mentality is really
no longer the business value or the
business proposition so
what do media companies like what are
media companies now right if
if if the consumer is everywhere else
and there's not really a direct
relationship outside of subscription
products and
if they're not delivering the content
and if they're not managing the
relationships with advertisers and
driving that revenue
um what is the positive to being a media
company which is kind of the
the the um perspective that i tried to
take and that really is kind of this
notion of managers of talent
right like there is a ton of value when
i speak to creators
for creating under the umbrella of a
larger brand
um i think that there's a huge uh
that there's a huge belief i won't say
like this like like
disbelief but there is a huge belief
that every creator wants to be
independent
and that's really not the case when you
talk to a lot of them there's a ton of
value especially in news media
to write for the washington post the new
york times it gives reputation it gives
access and enables you to have a book
deal and
grow your audience and then eventually
you decide to do what you want to do
after that but there is tremendous value
there
but media companies were never really
set up for that from a business
perspective right they were
essentially employing writers employing
creators to create content under an
umbrella
and the revenue models was advertising
on that content and subscribing to that
content
and if you blew up a creator's
reputation they would often leave
and go somewhere else and build their
own business if their reputation wasn't
great enough then they were so poor kind
of creator
and there really was no formula that
incentivized um
these creators to essentially like build
for the brand in a way that benefits
both them
and the brand so the media label or
sorry the
media company has record label ideas
kind of like well
if media companies know how to manage
talent how to distribute talent how to
work across the entire
uh kind of media ecosystem how to drive
revenue from it
then if i'm an independent creator and
if i'm set up with options which is
basically like
could i go and create on my own yes
there's benefit of being independent and
owning my ip
but now all of a sudden i'm my own
manager i'm my own distributor i have to
figure all this [ __ ] out that i have no
idea
what to do there um or right if the
economics makes sense i could go to a
media company they handle all of these
things for me
and it starts to kind of change the game
now media companies aren't there yet
like that's the one thing that i kind of
like lay out there but that
to be crystal clear they don't realize
that they need to be this yet
and i'm pushing it uh hard and i think
it's like becoming very very obvious
when you start to unravel it
but media companies need to rethink a
lot of things if they do become labels
like one of which is
what's the relationship with the creator
it's not just hey here's salary
come create content it's what's the
relationship with joint ip
if we create something and you leave the
company then what are the royalties tied
to this sort of
relationship how does the media company
get incentivized to allow like
pop to go and do his own thing even off
their platform because there's mutual
benefits there
and same for you know pomp to go and do
things that then drive back to the media
company so the economics are still being
worked out
but um in a very in a very rash way of
saying it i don't
like i firmly believe that media
companies don't figure that out like how
to
cultivate talent how to recruit talent
how to build business models out of
maintaining it like
really really looking at writers and
designers and editors and everything
that
allows that process to flow as actual
artists
and build models according to that then
i think more and more
artists are going to go somewhere else
where that's going to be accommodated
what you're seeing right you're seeing
sub stack you're seeing
a lot of platforms starting to take that
role where they were just distributors
now they're saying well look we could
become media companies as well
so it's really kind of coming to a head
right now and it feels to me like
there's
two separate trends that are happening
uh and and you're trying to pull them
back together right and those trends are
uh the mainstream media organizations
are losing and i put losing it in kind
of air quotes because it's how you
perceive it but
uh they're losing uh trust with the
public they're losing
individual creators that previously
wanted to work for them go off and on
their own
uh in some cases some are losing revenue
others are gaining revenue so that was a
little bit more up in the air
and even at some point you're seeing uh
organizations
lose uh readership on certain platforms
so you may see
somewhere that you were super successful
on facebook and all of a sudden that's
getting taken away that type of stuff
right and so it's not uh all doom and
gloom right obviously you see things
like the new york times right those
numbers get published and they're at
all-time highs in terms of subscribers
and things like that but
i think generally as a sector that
there's some struggles or obstacles
then on the other trend you see is
people leaving as the individual creator
and what's interesting to me is
historically people have thought about
uh the journalist as a
kind of a subsidiary of the media
company now you're seeing that break
away
and it's not just journalists though
right you're seeing everyone from
um an entrepreneur to an investor to a
journalist like anyone who basically can
do analysis or share an opinion about
something
the tools are now in place so you get
you know the substance
you can literally do audio video and uh
written content all by yourself
and do it pretty successfully right and
so what i think you're trying to figure
out is like
how do you take those two trends and
actually align the value proposition
so that the creators want to work with
the organizations the organizations get
value in the short and long term from
working with the creators is that kind
of a fair
yeah yeah i mean i mean so much unpacked
there but definitely
right i think i think the um the example
of the new york times is very
interesting right i think they
they were one of the first at least
legacy media companies that
i've started to um see
trying to take an approach that does put
kind of the talent front and center like
there was an article in neiman labs
a few months ago that says for the first
time the morning newsletter
is not going to be called like new york
times morning like the new york times
morning newsletter but it's going to
actually have
the author's name on it because they're
looking to build a brand around that you
see
taylor lorenz and cory sika and ben
smith and
big talent um that can easily go and
create their own brands and build their
own businesses
going there right and i think that that
is a very interesting trend to look at
because it's kind of an acknowledgement
from the new york times
basically saying like yes like we
are a media company like there is value
attributed to our brand that is why
people subscribe that is why advertisers
advertise against us
but we do also understand that we need
to evolve as a business
so as the future of news starts to
figure out like what that looks like and
what a netflix and news could look like
and what
the value of content looks like then all
of a sudden they start to think about
their role of recruiting and bringing
that talent there versus that talent
going elsewhere
um but i do i mean i'm i'm very bullish
on the
independent creator space like i like
that's basically why i've been
uh so involved in thinking through this
and um somewhat
trying to like poke holes in it by
trying to figure out okay if
if we see this trend happening and it is
happening right like someone said to me
the other day
um yeah it kind of seems like this would
have happened like this was supposed to
happen a decade ago and now they're
saying that it's going to happen again
but isn't actually happening
and and i think that's a narrow vision
because you look at youtube you look at
tik-tok you look at these media networks
that are distributors for these creators
and the top creators aren't the new york
times
vox media the washington post it's these
independent creators that have figured
out how to build their business within
this sort of new ecosystem
without that legacy debt right like that
legacy
in fact does kill the dream those legacy
operations
do inhibit you from being able to like
understand how the media
industry is evolving and as far as i'm
concerned that's already happened
on these new platforms right and um
i tweeted something out this morning
which is really which is like
very obvious too but like i think that
it starts to spark an interesting
conversation
it's always been a conversation of like
publishers versus the platforms right
like
media companies first the platforms how
much media companies give the platform
should platforms be paying media
companies
and i think the entire time platforms
knew
that they are that that they had already
become the media companies right they
were already the place
that both the new york times and both an
individual creator was going to go to
to create content and media companies
wanted to believe that they're competing
competing and competing but they're
really not right and now media companies
have become creators
now if they're 900 person newsroom
creators
that's great but they're the equivalent
of a creator creating on tick tock
as an independent creator is creating on
tick tock so
what kind of that convergence to your
point what that allows us to start to
think about is
what are the new businesses and
companies that are going to be built
that help create like comfort and
confidence for creators
i think that's obvious in the media
company sector like they basically do
that already they just need to figure
out
how to make themselves more attractive
so that creators still
want to stay there and come there but
then there's this whole other space
right which you saw with like sub stack
announcing legal
um coverage and conversations around
health insurance and conversations
around like
a collective like what uh the sub stack
people
uh have that type house group where they
all kind of come together and support
each other
that in itself is going to evolve into
businesses and opportunities
that are going to compete directly with
all of these media companies and now
it's kind of a race to figure out
who becomes the next like supportive
media company business model
that enables these creators to go um and
kind of like the fastest race there so
it is a convergence but it's also a
competition
and so let's talk about the media
companies specifically right so if
you're a media company today
historically your promise to a creator
has been come here i'll give you the
safety net of a salary you know what
you're going to get paid
um and there's probably some brand uh
kind of promise or brand backing you so
give some
version of legitimacy whether you needed
it or not there's some built-in audience
and we're hoping that you'll help us
grow that more but there's already this
built-in audience associated with our
brand
uh you get health insurance and legal
defense kind of all of these other
elements
uh and then on top of all of that uh you
also are going to be
have your work kind of uh bundled with a
bunch of other people who
uh either write about related topics or
maybe even unrelated topics but together
we're gonna put forward a product
and then we'll go do all the ad sales
and basically worry about the
monetization right
and so that for a long time was like a
pretty good
deal right if you wanted to create
content like why not go do that
now i think your argument is like that's
got to shift and so talk to me about
what in that offering do they not need
to offer anymore and then what are the
things that they actually
do need to offer that previously wasn't
part of the deal yeah
yeah that's a great question so so one
thing that you highlight
is that and that i think is often like
overlooked in the media space is that
media companies aren't bundles
like you just mentioned there's like the
post has a thousand journalists right
there's
there's a ton of writers running on a
ton of beats and a ton of sections
there's kind of this desire um that's
often brought up on twitter which is
like we just want
one new subscription that we then get
access to the times and the journal and
the post
but then you're when you peel it back
you're like they're all competing
bundles right in their
in their own companies and in their own
thinking they were trying to expand
coverage
and essentially be like a netflix or you
know enough of a bundle of content that
you are going to go there want to
subscribe and get everything that you
need
um i think traditionally like you're
right media companies did provide that
support there's a lot of value in
the opportunity to build your brand
there right the legitimacy
of having that brand the access i think
something that's
often um not discussed enough is this
idea of breaking news
right like when you think about the uh
kind of life cycle of content right now
you have breaking news and then you have
like curation commentary then
aggregation then [ __ ] just goes and
floats in the ether and hopefully pops
back up again but without that breaking
news
that like chain like doesn't work well
and a lot of breaking news is happening
at these media companies right because
if you're covering something in politics
you're covering something in sports
you know having it come from um like
breaking from an espn versus breaking
from
like a random independent writer um a
lot of
a lot of like people will want to break
news with those larger corporations with
those larger
um uh uh um kind of holding companies so
so it really is still a critical part of
the life cycle for creators that is
still attracted because
you have that overhead um you have that
reputation to build your brand
i've spoken to a lot of friends who have
gotten furloughed or laid off right now
in media because that is happening like
more and more and more often
um and i've asked them about starting up
their own independent companies and they
said look
i would take health insurance over going
independent any day
which of course is a preference not
everyone feels that way but there is
kind of this mixed sentiment of
this assumption of do these creators and
writers actually want to be
entrepreneurs
right or are they happy creating and you
know working for
the larger company to build that
reputation and not want to handle the
rest
um to answer your question like what
needs to be created
right is kind of that other approach now
right which is creators do
want to become entrepreneurs right they
believe that they are bringing
ip and bringing unique value to the
brand
and to do that then the economics need
to change
so to give you an example right now i
forgot the name of the podcast but there
was a podcast
created for buzzfeed um
and now the creators
want to kind of renegotiate ip and
license management and rights because
it's their name on the podcast
and you know they kind of built the
audience and built the brand under the
buzzfeed umbrella
um but because of that the economics are
set up it doesn't make sense right
buzzfeed probably said
hey look we'll pay your salary we'll
take you on we'll pay for the entire
show
you know how much production costs and
time costs they they
they they eat all of that and that is an
exchange
for the creators to be able to create
this content that they could then
monetize together
you're kind of seeing this desire now
where creators maybe they didn't realize
how things were set up maybe they didn't
understand the business side
as well and now they're educating
themselves more to them saying look like
this ip is tremendously valuable right
and i want to be able to
like own this especially like whether i
work here whether or not and
or whether i work here whether i don't
and so forth so i think the biggest
things that like media companies need to
shed
is this notion that like our biggest
value is our umbrella brands
i think that's not the case i think
that's like tremendously valuable
for creators to come there and want to
work there but the whole
emphasis really needs to be on how do
you make these creators job better how
do you give them more independence how
do you give them more value so that you
essentially represent them
as an agency wherever they're creating
whether that's tick-tock whether that's
facebook whether that's audio
and so forth on the flip side it's also
rethinking about
what those economics look like so if i
am going to join a media company
right now it would be i take a salary i
get health insurance
i have overhead coverage but maybe it
changes to hey look i don't want a
salary
or i want 20 salary but i want 50 of all
the ip that i'm creating
i want to be able to own that ip for 25
years right if that's licensed or
syndicated to netflix and so forth
and those companies i think you'll see
really start to like
make the biggest significant changes and
i think companies like
in new media like buzzfeed and vox do
already think like that i think
traditional media is where it's gonna
become a bit more
yeah and so obviously a lot of this is
uh
you've got old kind of legacy media not
old in a negative connotation just
they're been around for a long time
right and it's an advantage they're like
200 years old yeah
yeah and by the way and it's an
advantage and a disadvantage depending
on
what you're talking about um but the
other thing you've got changing is the
types of creators and so you wrote a
piece
uh all about this like renaissance
creator talk a little bit about what is
a renaissance creator
and kind of elaborate on what that
exactly means for uh for
kind of the creator industry if you will
yeah yeah so um
a lot of the kind of software and and uh
products that are being built today is
really around this idea of
creator independence right and when you
think about
what that like like who that typical
creator is
um it's usually this idea of someone who
works for a media company
who's built a big audience and is very
critical for driving that media
company's business
and now is going to branch out and
create their own kind of company and
business on their own
but there's also this flip thing
happening right now
um which i'm actually curious how you
bucket yourself honestly
um which is basically entrepreneurial
minds people that have maybe built their
own businesses
or that have built businesses within
media companies and are now saying
i'm a creator right so it's not like
your background's journalism
right you created a blog you're a
designer
right and that's your pathway to
becoming an independent creator and
that's why this trend of what's
happening on tick tock and subsec
um is is beneficial for you but it's
actually the inverse
right it's people who have maybe had
like more of a business mind have built
businesses have expertise there
that are now entering the arena and
saying we're independent creators too
we're going to create on topics and
they're learning in parallel which is
like amazing right you have people with
journalist backgrounds or creator
backgrounds who have left these
companies
who are now jumping in and can easily
create and understand that flow but now
they have to figure out how do i build a
business
what do i charge who do i work with how
do i distribute
and then on the flip side you have these
entrepreneurs coming in or these
business heads coming in
basically saying i know how to build a
business i know distribution i know how
to do all those economics
but like i need to figure out like how
do i write how do i pace right where do
i create so like how do i do a podcast
and that's kind of this notion of the
renaissance creator which is
we've created an environment with these
platforms which is like
awesome like i'm hyper obsessed with it
and you know
i feel like everywhere you look people
are talking about these things but it's
that
anybody now can really enter the arena
to create their own brand to create
their own media company you do not have
to have
any particular background in fact the
weirder the background or the most
unconventional that step up
the more successful you will likely be
because you'll have something to say
it'll be different it'll be relatable to
people who are also thinking in that
scope
um and there's so many things that kind
of fall into that bucket as i dove into
this idea of like
what does that typical creator look like
in this new kind of renaissance era
and and and and how do they enter the
playing field and there's all these
different analogies that come about like
one of which is this idea of
newsletters everyone has a newsletter
everyone's like it's a bubble
or or it's the future right there's like
all of these strong feelings
um on other side of it but what
newsletter is really allowed is like
this low barrier to entry
for anyone to be able to say okay i have
something to say i'm gonna create it and
i'm gonna put it out there
and it's become something that's very
interesting because the relationship is
one-to-one
you can kind of go at its low production
value it's like
the written word literally you don't
have to produce video you don't have to
produce audio like you're just putting
thoughts and content out there
and it's essentially like in an like in
an analogy to the music industry like
if you are an artist right and you
create a mixtape
you don't have to go into the studio you
don't have to be signed by a label you
don't have to do all these things
if you're talented you just go and as
you go you have an interesting path to
really becoming like a celebrity right
when you're a mixtape creator
or a newsletter creator your audience is
coming along for the ride
they're paying they're essentially
investing in you like i can't tell you
how many
sub stacks i subscribe to that i won't
unsubscribe
because i have such a strong
relationship with that creator and i
want them to succeed
even if i don't like the content i'll
stomach the bill because i want them to
succeed
i don't feel that relationship with
these larger media companies are holding
companies right so it's just a whole
different approach to like that business
and how it grows
and this notion of like now being able
to build that and leverage that right so
in this notion of like
renaissance creator anyone could step in
anyone could be a media company anyone
can build a media business
you now have in like the old worlds like
five years ago where you had a separate
strategy for facebook and youtube
or not separate strategy with separate
audiences for like facebook youtube
sub stack audio now you're like how do i
port that stuff over which again i feel
like i'm talking to someone who does
this in real time so
hopefully it relates to you but like
everything that these newsletter writer
like like everything you built on
twitter you can now port over to a
newsletter you start to create that
newsletter audience you can now port
that over elsewhere and you're not just
kind of a unique entity per platform all
the platforms are now working for you
and pushing you forward so there's
there's like a ton of different kind of
um angles that we could take there like
that we're kind of
like dug in on in the piece but it
really is this idea that
um before right if you wanted to join a
media company or be a creator
um whether that's in news or you know in
publishing
or in broadcast there was a very like
obvious way to get there and it was
limiting for most now it's basically
limiting to none
and it's hyper competitive and has
opened up this notion of a free market
where
you're not just getting a salary to
create for a brand you essentially are
getting the value attributed to you
of the output of the work that you're
actually doing if you could build a
business
you can make a ton of money if you
understand how to flex a maneuver
you can do this all on your own you
don't need that overhead so
the options are there and it's just kind
of inverted the entire funnel of
what this media economy looks like yeah
when i read the piece the part that was
most interesting to me is you break down
um historically people think of creators
as creators
first and then they may be able to
figure out how to monetize that
what all of these platforms have done
though is they've allowed entrepreneurs
whether they're venture funded you know
kind of tech types uh
founders or just entrepreneurial in
nature
to now start to build these content
businesses right it's almost like the
the cost of starting one of these
businesses has drastically been driven
down by the substance by the youtubes
by the podcasting platforms very similar
to what we saw let's say with server
costs right
there was an explosion of startups uh
that that um
happened because simply now you could
spin up aws rather than have to go buy a
server and set it up
and so that to me is interesting because
what you
get is a blurring of the line right is
somebody who
um you know let's take away all of our
investing activity everything if you
just look at the things that i've done
in on the content side
is it that you're an entrepreneur or is
it that you're a creator and what's the
difference
right and you can kind of go down
whether it's the sub stack list or or
other platforms
and you start to actually look at the
skill set that's necessary
is very different than the skill set of
hey just go work inside the media
company
right and so i think that that's the
other piece of this where everyone's
like oh all the
uh all the journalists are going to
leave the media organizations like ah
there's a lot of people who actually are
not entrepreneurial that not at all like
they're scared
they just want to stay where they are
safe get a salary
and they're perfectly happy but it's not
a bad thing they're happy doing that
but then there is a subset of people and
the question is how big is that subset
that want to go do this and i think
that's kind of what you're hitting at
here is
are those people creators that were
doing it already and now building a
business
or were they business people who now are
seeing an opportunity and they're coming
in and creating uh
what any kind of content really yeah
yeah no uh
i mean it's so right on right i think i
think everybody
a lot of people are saying like okay
when you go and become your own
you know creator business you go and
create a sub stack you go and create you
know a brand on tick tock
um that now you get to just focus on
doing what you do best creating
and it's the opposite it's like when you
decide to go and do that
you're actually assuming the business of
your entire self you're basically saying
yes i'm going to create
but i am now choosing and willingly
going to take on
all of this work in order to help build
my brand my business
and really try to figure out
entrepreneurially how we go there and
that's a totally different skill set
um i think that's why
right now some of like the earliest
people in this space especially
like in that sub stack crew but even
newsletter creators like webb smith
um that have done it outside um they're
here to stay
right i think everyone who's kind of in
at this moment
has really figured out what they need to
do in order to kind of like support
their own business
how to kind of manage certain times how
to focus on distribution and really be
able to see what's next
um the next but that also on top of that
i think that's also um an
acknowledgement that
we probably have one percent of the
creators that are like
interested and willing to like leave and
do it because of that
um that need for them to be able to own
it all right that's a particular person
that could really do that this next
phase of like
creator economy passion economy or
whatever you want to call it
there's so much focus and people that
i'm talking about that are or people
that i'm talking to and
um people that are investing in the
space around that notion of
comfort and confidence right so if you
know that right now it takes a
particular creator
who really understands not just how to
build audience and create but also
manage a business
then how do you start to attract the
millions and millions and millions of
other people
who would be willing to come over and do
this if
they weren't so nervous about health
insurance if they weren't so nervous
about getting sued and liable
if they weren't so um nervous about the
fact that they don't have an editor or
don't have a designer or don't have
newsroom support
and what's incredible is that is not
going to be a catalyst for people to not
come over that's actually going to be a
catalyst for
builders to build those products and
build those sort of networks and
marketplaces and support
in order to recognize that that pool is
a ton of people
that would be willing and interested to
come over if those things are built so
that's really like
the next phase of what's happening here
i think phase one was okay
can creators go out and do this on their
own and are there enough tools for them
to be able to actually create and put
content
out there now it's okay how do we build
things that help support that business
which kind of goes full circle to the
emphasis of media companies at record
labels
it's not really a choice i think if they
if they don't figure out
how to structure their companies in
order to focus on creators
and build for creators to manage that
sort of talent and delivery
then these companies are going to be
built outside of them and things are
just going to run
right so it's kind of no longer a choice
but more so
starting to kind of make that transition
and make that approach but
one more thing that's really interesting
on top of that though is like and i talk
about this in renaissance creator is
that
newsletters kind of had the same effect
as streaming
in a very weird way right like the music
industry was kind of dead when napster
came out and napster didn't come out
because people wanted free music right
napster was
basically developed because no one could
stand the ux of the music experience no
one wanted to buy
um a 20 cd you know at whatever your
local record store was
for a single track um nobody likes like
how bulky and um kind of the cost
structure and everything around that
experience
to the point where like sean parker and
code built napster
to basically say okay we're gonna build
an experience that consumers actually
want when it comes to listening to music
and what came out of that right via
spotify
was that not only did people stop
stealing music but now they're paying
for it right because it's an experience
they like it's a relationship they like
there's a ton of arguments that can be
thrown at me which i get all the time at
twitter which is like is it better for
the artist
separate conversation but for the
consumer right napster and streaming
really kind of broke through and built a
better business
for music than it was when it was
totally broken down via the napster era
newsletters are kind of the same right
like we're forgetting now because of
all the media growth that two or three
years ago
you had an ad blocker on right you
didn't want to go to a
site and read content and see ads and
you chose to turn that blocker on
you would bypass paywalls constantly
right like you like
mainly like maybe you wouldn't even go
and see that content or you'd type the
url into google
and you'd circumvent it you did not want
to pay for content
and you didn't not want to pay for
content because you didn't believe
content was valuable you just didn't
like that experience
right and what newsletters have done in
a very weird way
is really broken that one-to-one
relationship again right and there's
like weird
synergies it's like i get say i get your
newsletter in my inbox
there's nothing stopping me from
forwarding your newsletter to 10
11 i mean there's tracking and stuff but
there's ways to go about it
but nobody does that right nobody does
that because there's a relationship with
the creator
they like the way that it's being
delivered to them they like the
experience there's a value exchange
and they know what they're paying for
and they think that that's valuable and
they're getting that back
so it's kind of changed like the
newsletter ecosystem
has kind of also changed the way that
the broader media ecosystem
really thinks about the value of content
because of that and i kind of believe
that
it was like less severe but the napster
moment was kind of
ad blocking paywalls users are fed up
with that way of navigation content here
comes newsletters or independent
creators that are building a new
relationship value exchange
and now all of a sudden people are like
oh yeah content is valuable and i do
like this and media companies are
starting to adjust
the way that they operate in order to
accommodate that ux
and it's kind of a similar sort of slope
um that i think is just really
really really badass to pay attention to
and it feels like as this is occurring
um the newsletter you mentioned it
earlier right and exactly what i did
which was
go build on twitter first you can pull
them to newsletter they can kind of go
to a platform by platform
but the newsletter specifically is kind
of the most censorship resistant thing
that we have currently
right i get to send something direct
into your inbox you've opted into
receiving that thing
yes there is the ability for uh let's
say gmail to kind of filter and put you
into spam and you know it's not perfect
but more so than let's say the
algorithms when it comes to social media
or anything like that
it is the most one-to-one authentic
thing that we have
and does it feels like that's the way
we're trending so there's gonna be more
people who want more of that
and whether that goes to other platforms
whether there's platforms built
specifically for this
it's just the idea of like removing the
middleman right and i wrote today about
this idea of like
within a media organization today what
we basic or inside of an industry what
we basically have is we've got
three types of content creators right
you've got journalists
which actually practice like the art of
journalism so
it's unbiased no opinion all fact
checked you know kind of all the things
that we that we associate with
journalism
you then have a category that i call
bloggers and i didn't and i clear
you know clearly say like i don't think
of that as a negative uh connotation
it's just these are people who have a
different process for publishing than
journalists do and it's usually more
opinion based and
then then you've got what i call market
participants so in the finance world
these are
all the investors and people who are
creating content but they're actively
practicing
you know the craft and my point was like
those three things
are actually all valuable for different
pieces
but what i wonder is that
middle group the bloggers right there's
not as much
downside risk for when they create
content so you've got let's say
investors where
they're actively putting money to work
and if they're wrong the market goes
against them and they lose money right
so there's some risk to kind of
how you um think about things and an
intellectual rigor that goes into this
is you make because
there's money online journalism it feels
like um
there's almost this community of people
that uh fact check each other
meaning that you know if you're a
journalist and i'm a journalist and you
write something that's factually
inaccurate
there's somebody else that is going to
just you know absolutely light you up
and be like no dude you got it wrong
right and so there's kind of this like
you know eat what you kill but you
better be accurate
you know community of journalism that
middle group
what i i still don't understand yet
right is
the thing that i've labeled as blogger
feels like they're not held to the
journalistic standards
they also don't have skin in the game
and so it's just this constant
regurgitating of
my opinion my opinion my opinion and
what i am wondering is like is that the
ideal group
to go in and leave and become these
creators right
and also the market participants you get
two of the three groups or the prime
suspects to go leave
but the journalists end up staying
because they actually are the ones that
need the most
infrastructure right they're the ones
who need the editors the fact checkers
the legal
defense all that kind of stuff and maybe
just talk through you know you can use
those three labels or think of it
differently but like
who inside of a traditional media
organization is most likely to leave
and is it just are you entrepreneurial
or are you not or is it actually the
type of content you create
can really um hint at whether you're
likely to leave or not
yeah no it's so it's so interesting that
you say that because one
i realized that a lot of a lot of people
don't understand the separation
between news and opinion within a
traditional news organization like how
severe it actually is so news and
opinion literally sit on different
floors
within the building they're uh they have
different editors
um the way that the business is managed
the way that converse like conversations
aren't had between one another because
news can't be influenced by opinion and
opinion shouldn't be influenced by news
so they literally operate separately
however the way the business models work
is
it essentially is the same right it's
the same subscription unless you
break them out but across the entire
media company advertising is still
across
you know particular audiences so even
though there's so much work being done
to separate it
the business still treats it the same so
thus people often bucket things
in the same and you see this all the
time right like on twitter if somebody
posts something even if it's an opinion
from the new york times or the wall
street journal or
the washington post it's very hard for
the casual reader to understand what's
an opinion what's not and then you have
conversations well this is fake news or
why are they writing about this and
traditional media companies will say
like
well it's opinion and it's not news and
people should know but they don't know
right and it's been hundreds of years of
trying to educate
um how these things operate and the
nuances of it but readers still don't
understand and it drive
and it just causes a lot of like
conversations and differentiations when
it comes to like
how how it should exist and how it
should exist further uh
you hit it on the head i think i think
opinion writers
within media companies um are the ones
that are most likely to go independent i
think you've already seen it with
andrew sullivan uh from new york media
who left
um there's like rumblings of a few
recent new york times
uh journalists who have left on the
opinion side to go over to a sub stack
but
i think traditionally when you think
about what opinion writers
do and how they create and how they
build audiences um
there's a natural progression for them
to build build kind of
media companies or voices on their own
there are also a lot of interesting
things opinions drive
a ton of subscriptions for traditional
media companies right so like
even though on the new side right it's
very um
it's very unbiased it's indifferent
right with how that's reported
a lot of people subscribe because of you
know the opinion writers within
within a news organization in fact a lot
of them subscribe to particular writers
which is pretty
you know well sorry they don't subscribe
to particular writers they subscribe
because of particular writers which is a
huge bull case for
a sub stack if they're betting like
banking on the fact that
they could get a writer to leave and
that will bring a massive amount of
audience i think like those assumptions
are
are are very accurate so i do think that
that's the case i think that
people who would consider leaving media
companies i think the opinion side
is kind of the most obvious like
early on because exactly we said the
fact checking
the uh like even though fact checking
and research and those things are
important
needing edit meeting design etc like
isn't as critical as it is from the news
side
uh they already have their own audiences
and have
often times built a lot of their own
reputation on the platform so
a lot of the opinion writers are kind of
building their own
kind of chorus on twitter and on youtube
and so forth and they kind of have that
audit
audience and move aside that third
category that you mentioned market
uh what did you call them market
participants
yeah market participants i think is like
why i'm also so bullish on the creator
economy because it's essentially saying
like we're gonna recognize new talent
and bring that new talent up
and build fame out of them right so we
look at kind of the idea of like
renaissance creator and how people kind
of
get to this and build their own brand
there's people that already create
content under big brands that are highly
reputable that can move that over
um whether that's news or whether that's
opinion um
there's people that are starting up and
building that on a particular network
and then porting that over
but then i think there's people that
you'll start having conversations with
like within your own communities like
like a big thing with sub stack right
now that i'm hearing a lot of writers
talk about is like
there's a great up like it's currently
set up in a great way for them to
communicate directly with their audience
to deliver content right to put that in
their inbox
and you know have a direct conversation
they could reply directly to that writer
but what's that next iteration of
connecting community to one another like
i'm a member of x um like
i subscribe to x writer i then want to
engage with other people within that
community
the tools to do that aren't really there
and i think that that's going to start
to surface that third bucket
which is market participants where we're
going to start to be pulling out
creators
from communities of existing like
independent creator
media platforms that are then going to
start to be building things on their own
and you'll start to see like in a
similar way to
what's happened with people growing
followers on twitter because of like
certain point of views
to people becoming creators on youtube
you'll see that within the written space
so it won't just be limited to
like i worked in a media company or i'm
a business entrepreneur that has done
something that has already built an
audience and came here i think we'll
start to see
new creators cultivated out of that
community and out of those conversations
which nailed that third bucket which i
think is like
right on in very early days yeah and the
part to me
uh that is so fascinating is
uh take the most extreme example so take
a joe rogan right which it seems like
everybody
and their mom at some point has tried to
cancel joe rogan and you know from the
mainstream media
and frankly some of it's because uh they
got nothing better to do some of it's
because he said things that they
disagree with you know
whatever the reasoning is but when you
break it down he has a bigger audience
than they have
and that and then to me like that is
like whoa hold on time out a second
you're telling me that the individual
creator has built a bigger
business and a bigger audience than many
of the people that
work at these big brands and so it
almost
feels like uh there's going to be this
switching mentality from
oh if i stay at this one organization
i'm going to be able to reach x number
of people but if i
leave and i execute correctly i can
reach x
times five right now i can't actually
reach a bigger number of people
and that would you know uh traditionally
lead to more revenue but i do it all as
an individual creator rather than
trying to do it here under this brand so
maybe talk a little bit about like
what happens in a world where the
individual creators are actually bigger
than the media
yeah yeah so this is like something
that's really interesting that kind of
goes
uh to what we were saying earlier which
is like
media companies have always thought that
they're competing with platforms but
they're not right i think i think
platforms are the
kind of bridges and tunnels of how all
creators deliver their content or you
know their products throughout
throughout the web ecosystem um i think
media companies are actually competing
with creators
right and and that's kind of their role
now
and you'll see that um media companies
will have the opportunity to bring more
creators on and start to accumulate that
audience
but because of how things are set up
right now like my independent audience
right as a writer
maybe that i build on twitter isn't
necessarily associated with the umbrella
brand because there's no incentive to do
so
right so the larger incentive right now
exactly to your point is
i'm getting so big that if i get so big
i should just branch out and build my
own business because
the economics for me to say aren't as
you know great as the economics for me
to leave so
um one like one thing to hit on which
you were saying which i think is very
true is media companies are creators
right and if
if if platforms are leveling the playing
ground for
a joe rogan or you know a vox media or
a bar school sports um then they're all
competing on the same playing field and
they need to think about how they can
strengthen
their own individual company or their
own individual brands
to compete against that i think if um
any lifestyle company
right doesn't think that they're
competing directly with joe rogan
they're way off right and in fact they
should be looking at that right people
people
could hate barstool all they want and
things that are coming out of there but
you look at how that business has
diversified
you look about how they uh create talent
how they build individual brands out of
their talent
how they think about license and ip and
things that you know traditional
organizations don't think about
they've diversified themselves way more
right than any traditional company has
which is usually built up the idea of
like subscriptions and advertising right
so
um it's really this this this
acknowledgement that
independent creators have the
opportunity to grow a bigger audience
and grow a bigger brand
than that of umbrella companies and if
that is the case
how do you set up your company in order
to attract those creators there and the
answer may be
it eventually becomes impossible right
there may be so much work happening
um within like the platform space
where we're building so many tools and
so many bit like
like business opportunities and
operational support that
individual creators are the media
companies and they're just sharing tools
what's really interesting to to kind of
highlight to kind of bring this back to
some of the work happening at wapo too
is that
when we like about eight eight nine
years ago
at the washington post we really started
to think about how we could expand our
businesses beyond just like what's
happening on the washingtonpost.com
owned and operated
and what was a very obvious one one
being owned by jeff bezos we had to
figure out
how we actually become a technology
company because everyone expected us to
become a technology company
um but two it was like where can we
actually expand right and we're like
we're a media company
we create content we're trusted we
distribute that content
um but all the tools that we use to do
that are outside tools we license them
we work with companies whether it's
content management system workflow
management systems so forth
so we said okay let's invest in building
that right and let's build something
better
than we have today that we could use for
the post to make the post stronger
that has then translated to us now
powering like 1300 sites across the
world
a lot of publishers like the boston
globe chicago tribune
dallas morning news and so forth but the
the crazy thing
um is that you started to see a shift
with these media companies because they
were so
um they were so financially lucrative
and growing over the past two decades
they decided to bring everything
in-house they're like okay we create
content
but we're going to be a technology
company so we're going to build a
content management system and have all
this in-house
what we've seen when we built ark is now
these media companies
are like we're not technology companies
we can't compete
it doesn't make sense we're going to
license it and we're going to focus on
creating
now with zeus which is our next kind of
business which is focused on revenue for
media companies
it's a similar thing just like these
media companies said
we're not technology companies we're not
going to stop that anymore we're going
to license it
we're now seeing that on the revenue
side these media companies are like
we're not ad tech companies
we're not really consumer marketing
companies we staff it but we're not as
good as other places
we're going to license that so then we
can reallocate resources elsewhere
so you're starting to see like a
centralized approach to technology
a centralized approach to revenue which
goes to like the final
like prediction which is a media company
eventually
whether you're one person or whether
you're a 300 person newsroom
is probably gonna be a ratio of 99 to
one like 99
creator right whether you're a 300
person creator room or won't create a
room
and one percent software you're not
going to have your own sales team
you're not going to have your own
engineering team you're not going to
have all these things that you now
manage as fixed cost overhead
you're going to license that because
it's not your identity but that really
accelerates this whole entire notion of
joe rogan being a media company
jamel hill is a great example she worked
for espn
all that happened she now creates and
and delivers and is getting paid by like
10 different media companies and
platforms like as her own brand
that is where everyone will go so like
what we're seeing right now is these
larger media companies
will start to like divest in different
areas that don't make sense for them
and focus more on content creation these
independent creators don't have the
legacy
debt they could start thinking about how
they can focus on growing audience
and leveraging the tools that are out
there um and being able to build on that
and we'll
see them meet in the middle on like a
very very very level playing field
and it feels also like all you're
getting is uh you're getting the
unbundling by getting all the creators
out from the media organization
uh but then you're getting rebundling
right which is basically joe rogan has
uh somebody who helps with ad sales so
he has somebody who helps them with the
production
right uh on sub stack we're seeing
bundling of newsletters together
um they're also providing you know the
legal assistance right which is exactly
what a
media company would do and so maybe talk
through a little bit like are we just
recreating the world
with different tools and platforms or is
there something that ends up actually
being different in kind of where we go
i think um i think that's
i think it's our responsibility to not
um to
i i think it's our responsibility to not
renovate
the business model and to actually build
a new foundation
um i think that if like
it's always the case that business
models drive product strategy right if
you're not making money
then you're not gonna do it and um if we
go through
a unbundling rebundling and
the models are still the same which is
where
advertising against content right people
are subscribing to
um bundle subscriptions and there's
nothing else
that evolves out of that then maybe we
have the opportunity to recalibrate our
businesses
build a more lean setup so that margins
and profits could be somewhat better
but then we could end up in the same
place what i'm seeing and what's most
exciting is that we're actually
not relying on those traditional models
i think there are
many extremes like subset believing that
advertising is not a good model i think
is like
crazy i'm not gonna push them on that
like if they're building that
they understand their business like they
could continue doing that but
we are entering a world where
advertising is completely changing
third-party cookies are going away it's
all about context and content and like
sub sac is literally a breeding ground
for that and could
actually become like the next facebook
or fbx
like what that was for the web sub stack
could kind of do that
for this iteration of the web if they
wanted to go that route so really kind
of testing and thinking through new
models
i think bringing back old ideas like the
idea of like the wire service
i think is like something that we've
lost which is really interesting which
is
you creator create content um yes
there's like
licensing deals but how do we start to
create new mechanics around the idea of
well if this content is used or licensed
by others
or repurposed what are different
financial incentives and models that we
could build around that
i think that's very untapped right you
look at the music industry and you look
at
um the idea of like i create a song
i get paid like for streams or
royalties or things tied to that in in
kind of our content creation business
that doesn't really exist right like you
create content
it's out there and then it's kind of on
the go right maybe you license it once
but this idea of like long tail business
benefits really don't exist which i
think could start to exist
so i think in order for us not to
reinvent the wheel which is why
the art i mean again i'm biased i wrote
the articles but why they're
but why they're so hot right now is
because
one media companies are realizing that
their traditional business models aren't
working that advertising is owned by
facebook and google
that is the truth um and they'll
continue to grow that pie
and they have so much investment uh like
in building the next phase of that
publishers it's very hard for publishers
to compete there so publishers need to
think about like what is our new role
and new role being
you know focused on talent focused on
building new revenue models and
distribution models for that talent
starts to become a real business right
in a new arena that they get to move
into and build off of
on the other side of it it's really
trying to think about like how do we not
renovate these old business models or
renovate this old house and actually
build this new house right and build
this new business models
and really start to kind of focus on
what could be done there and um
and like you're kind of seeing that
right you're seeing that happen without
revenue tied to it like i love the idea
of type house what type house tells me
is that
all these writers are coming together
because there's all these services that
they need and want to share and work on
um which to me is a business right
people should be focused on building
those businesses
um health insurance right and and liable
are so
traditionally held and you know you need
to be an employer for a company so how
do you start to
separate the idea of like 1099 workers
and give benefits to those sort of
workers so that it's not just
to your point unbundling rebundling but
also saying okay
now you want all these benefits you now
have to be an employee a sub stack if
you're a writer these writers are going
to say no that's not why we joined in
the first place right so there needs to
be
new models bred out of that or else you
do risk kind of running into the same
thing but everything that i see
um right now is is is going in that
right direction is kind of saying
how do we blow this [ __ ] up and you know
figure out how to actually create
something
that's focused both on the creator and
then that next iteration is going to be
like
the consumer right and we're in a very
tight spot right now to figure that out
one thing you mentioned earlier if we go
deeper on this monetization theme
is uh this idea of like licensing the
content and so
for people that don't know today uh
somebody inside of a media organization
creates content they go ahead and
um it's published on that platform they
get paid a salary
and for the most part that's how it
works uh
in terms of moving forward is there a
world where
uh these media organizations say to
somebody hey we'll do a revenue share
so if you have an email that makes x you
know million dollars you get a piece of
it or
your articles the ads we sell against it
we'll keep track of for you specifically
and give you a cut on a percentage basis
um and then
as part of a second part of that
question talk about this licensing idea
of like after i leave i can still maybe
have a royalty stream uh
from the actual content yeah yeah so
so there is there is a ton of
attribution to individual creators
within these larger media companies or
you know we'll call them holding
companies because we're trying to
tie them as close to possible as the
music industry um
there is there
there there are stats there is data
looked at that
individual writers drive certain
business right so whether that's
um who's driving the most subscriptions
who's driving the most traffic
um that data is available now that data
isn't necessarily something that
is used from a business perspective or
set up from a business perspective but i
think that it starts to become
a opportunity to be leveraged when you
are
kind of trying to court or attract more
creators so
really being able to think through um
all right if you work here this is what
you drive
and there are certain tiers of that now
the one thing that i'd say is something
that
uh that constantly has brought up to me
as i push out these ideas is like
there are those layers in the middle
that are often unaccounted for
right like we know the byline writer and
that byline writer yes
is is definitely the dominant force to
that content being engaged with or
shared or viewed
um but those layers in between editor
designer
right are oftentimes not considered
within that
um within that value chain but they're
critical right so one thing to really
think about
as kind of working through those models
is really thinking about
how you start to expose that value as
well so you start to really attribute
all these different things
um on an inverse look what's really
interesting is like and i've kind of
brought i brought this up in the poet
days and we talk about it all the time
with the post and the times is working
on a project
um with adobe um that's
that's a blockchain project i think uh
sponsored by ibm garage
but really about the exposure of the
effort in that work right like
there there's this notion of like you
work in a company you're driving all
these benefits and that's recognizable
and how does that look and how does
licensing and setup and those things
look
but also on the other side it's like as
a reader i want to read content
and i will trust this content or engage
with this content more if you start
start to expose that same data to me
right like like was this fact checked
who's the writer of this um what links
are you
you know tied to it what's the
provenance of that information yes this
is source but who was the source
there's a couple different ways to do
that that both drive and kind of deliver
both of those models
um when it comes to the licensing thing
of people leaving afterwards i think
that's the most
interesting thing for a lot of companies
to start thinking and talking about and
i do know a couple media companies
today that are already kind of thinking
about this which is this idea that
traditionally it was a risk for media
companies
to like make celebrities out of their
writers right because
their salary employees um they're
creating under the umbrella so the whole
goal and focus always is like
to put the brand first and to push the
brand forward that's what you sign up
for absolutely
but if you start to kind of if if if a
creator starts to fly away
right which now think about how easy
that is with twitter every other
platform
you could like go viral and you could be
gone 30 years ago it was like you get to
pick up the phone to call someone and
tell them they had a great article right
like it just never happened
um but media companies were essentially
incentivized to like
not let that creator reputation fly and
not make them famous and you could look
at
actual examples like politico when ben
smith and maggie haberman maggie
haberman
now writes for the times of ben smith
now richard the times when he's formerly
editor-in-chief of buzzfeed
um they blew up at politico and they
left
right and they hit and like politico was
left there and they went off and
continued to build their brands
um there needs to be that
incentive for media companies to allow
that now because
one it benefits the media company like
and their brand if that
creator blows up creates content builds
a huge audience
that reflects on the brand right but the
brand's concern that that creator is
just gonna leave is
all tied to the incentive models right
it's all tied to the fact that like
you're not giving them an incentive to
stay right if there is
shared equity if there is more like like
a revenue opportunity or some sort of
ownership opportunity
or you can leave right to the example
they said
you can leave and you still own 20
of the ips so you are incentivized to
like go and create and even when you
leave that value eyepiece still remains
there's another radical idea that i'd
love to put out there which is basically
like
can media companies or uh like you
definitely see this in the venture space
right but in media companies
it doesn't happen if i'm an
up-and-coming creator
um maybe a media company wants to invest
in me as a brand right like we talk
about like tokenizing the individual and
you i could talk to about this because
you'll get it but some people are like
what the what's that
but like this idea that okay like you're
an up and coming creator on my platform
i'm gonna invest in you
i own 10 of you as a brand you go
do whatever you want that's going to
help build your brand because the
financial returns make sense to me
so like these mechanisms need to change
it's gonna happen i think it has to
happen
or else you know independent creators as
they grow up and there's more and more
and more opportunity
for them to get famous for them to drive
value drive popularity
they will leave unless those incentives
remain intact now i think news is a
like like news is unique because news is
very contingent on the brand
but that's a micro but that's a micro
topic on a way more macro trend that
we'll need to work out so lots to unpack
there yeah well
and i think that you're you're nailing
it in the sense of if you align the
incentives correctly
then a lot of things can change but
right now
it's one side of this relationship is
extracting way more value than the other
and that's almost cause think of like a
pendulum right like the pendulum swung
in the favor of the media companies
now there's tools and services that are
coming out that allow the pendulum to
swing back in the power of the creators
but actually we should find somewhere in
between right
somewhere somewhere in the middle of
that where it's a win-win for both
parties will
um kind of find harmony or equilibrium
in the market
rather than just allowing you know every
five to ten years the pendulum to swing
back and forth
it kind of just feels like you know you
never get to a steady state
um of a win-win type relationship yeah
it's
somebody said this morning that like the
middle class of publishing
is gone like there's no middle class in
publishing that you're either
like one of these independent creators
that's building on the platforms
or you're one of these larger holding
companies and i basically said it's kind
of the opposite like it could be looked
at in the inverse where like
everyone is kind of working on either
side back towards the middle
like sure the middle class is like gone
but everyone's trying to work back
towards that you have these media
companies
who in who over invested in so many
things outside of their business whether
that's
tech business like investment venture
like things that weren't tied to their
content or their main value proposition
which where which they're now trying to
divest in order to have a better kind of
fixed cost structure so that they could
be a profitable
media company and then you have these
independents that are basically saying
what's the minimal kind of like add-ons
i need to put in order to be a
successful company so that i'm not
over-bloated and i don't lose focus
and they're actually coming back towards
the middle and that's exactly right on i
think what happens is
everyone on this even playing field now
i don't know
like people are like is the next phase
for a lot of
these independent creators for media
companies to acquire them and like web
smith
said that you know there's been a couple
conversations happening that like
he hasn't entertained but he's been
approached um and then that starts to
open up this
notion of like what is that value of the
independent creator like you would
assume that a media company would want
to acquire them because their audience
but
you think like what i said earlier that
relationship of like me with that
creator as a
as a subscriber i'm going along for the
ride
feeling like they're a part of it and
growing it there's a huge
argument to be made that their
relationship with the subscriber is like
10x the relationship of a larger company
with the subscriber thus
is their value 10x is it like something
that they should never sell
there's like all these different things
that'll kind of factor and come to play
but
it's all happenings the last thing i
want to talk about is this idea of
um the creators actually using their
audience
not for just monetizing in the way that
you or i would think about monetizing
content
but actually being the top of the funnel
and really the
potential customer base for building
businesses
and we in the most extreme examples
we've seen kim kardashian kylie jenner
kanye west
kind of do this uh they are creators but
i think mainly we think of them as
celebrities that have audience and then
they were able to monetize it by
building a business
um one do you think that's going to
happen with the independent creators and
two have you seen anything there that
suggests like that might actually be
underway yeah people
i mean people have gotten mad at me for
saying that i think like
at least in the early days of like this
creator movement that you kind of have
to be famous
at least with sub stack i felt that you
really had to already have a
pre-existing audience or a pre-existing
following in order to port over
um i got slammed on people were pissed
that i said that and there was like two
examples that people gave me
people who actually built brands on on
like subscribe from the ground up but i
do
i do think that um this idea of
i mean look audience audience is
probably the
the the hardest most underappreciated
work that needs to happen for these
independent creators right it's
something that we constantly overlook
when we talk about
leaving media companies we're like
totally disregarding the fact that these
media companies allow them to build
audience right when we
talk about all the work that needs to be
done like creating content every day
and figuring out what cms to use you
forget about the fact that all this work
has to be done in order to accrue and
build that audience
so i think that i think that as
these creators find their platform of
choice and delivery
it really is kind of contingent on
or most beneficial for them to be able
to have another platform where that
audience is built to then port over
i think that there are kind of extremes
outside but
um the goal the goal too
right like you you use the word famous
and i do i do think that that's the goal
too right i think the goal
for these creators um as they start to
kind of build their brand and move over
between different platforms and kind of
grow kind of grow their influence
is in fact to become famous because as
you do become famous then you are able
to then
easily port over and go on to new
platforms go on and build new businesses
and be able to extend that
you can imagine a world right and like
there was an article in the journal
about this like that
that like the top musicians aren't
making music
like they're like 90 of their business
is being made from other [ __ ]
like if they're creating like a beverage
company or you know they
they they have a new network or you know
they're doing things through like
investments
and you can imagine that a similar
approach will probably
be taken for these independent creators
especially like the writers on sub stack
it's like
okay they're making money through
writing and building audiences now
but eventually they'll grow fame and
celebrity and popularity to the point
where now
they'll be able to leverage that not
have to do that for their business
be able to do that to your point to like
build more audience or just for fun
and allow all that work that they've
done to them be pivoted and moved over
to doing other things whether that's
you know being on a network or doing
television or broadcast or
being able to extend that kind of like a
jamel harris type approach like i think
like
that should be the goal it shouldn't be
i'm going to create a newsletter
i'm going to have you know a single
channel my career it's that oh i'm using
this in order to get to that next thing
and that's very rare and weird for
journalism because that's just
never been the case but again it's
happening and i think we'll see
similar kind of behaviors and
transitions there as we've seen with
every other industry
it's fascinating to me because uh i
think that it all comes back to the idea
that audience is the new currency
and if you have audience you're able to
push them between platforms you're able
to monetize them you're able to do all
kinds of things
but audiences kind of that that powerful
thing and that ultimately to your point
leads to
you know who owns the audience right so
um
you know if a no-name journalist and not
no name
in a negative sense but just they're
unknown uh joins a media publication
they build a massive twitter following
and then they leave
right was it the individual or the
publication that that created that
now today i think the default always is
and i personally believe it should be
in the hands of the creator um but but i
think that
that is a whole other strategy that we
will see we will literally see people
who want to be individual creators but
they'll go join somewhere
use that brand as a launching pad uh you
know probably the best example that
we've seen so far is pat mcafee
left the nfl joint barstool was there
for a decent amount of time
realized wait i can do this exact same
thing myself when and now he's got
i believe the largest youtube uh show
uh in terms of uh sports audience
yeah and so you look at that you're like
okay like
here's a dude who just left walked out
of the nfl learned built
you know kind of an audience with the
barcelona left and did it for himself
and i think he just signed like a big
multi-million dollar contract with
draftkings yeah it's like such a big
point
that like it's really interesting that
you say that right because i think
i think the the the common thinking is
that
you don't want to work at a media
company because you want to own that
audience right like when you
like early substance conversations were
like when you're creating for a
publisher they own your ip they own that
audience
come over here you own that ip you on
that audience which is true
but then on the inverse to your point if
you don't have an audience
right the audience literally isn't just
who's reading you on that publisher
your audience now becomes your twitter
following or any platform following so
you leverage that media company
in order to build that following that in
fact you are actually owning
and accruing your audience there and
porting that over i think that that's
the biggest thing though is like
the future media businesses are all
about interoperability it's really about
being able to build audiences places and
port them over
again you know that's probably better
than most people um
and and and and
creators are going to be kind of
focusing on those things where
and connecting those platforms and
connecting channels and connecting
content when they know that that
portability could exist
things that don't allow for that sort of
portability or that
kind of brand building or reputation
building i think are going to
start to become like very very very
uninteresting for or disinteresting for
a lot of these creators yeah it's a
fascinating world what's the one thing
that you're looking for in the future as
we wrap up
uh in terms of this specific trend or
this specific like milestone to happen
where you'll say hey that that's big
yeah so i think um i think
i think there's a couple things one is i
think the more
the more creators that start to come
over outside
of kind of like an opinion vertical that
are focused on
um like news right or things really
focused on
um like breaking news investigative
journalism and work there that is really
expensive
and it's like really hard and needs a
brand umbrella and reputation and i
think when you start
seeing that happen you can really start
to understand like
how this is actually going to break
apart i think right now what's very
clear is
there are a lot of exactly your point
like opinion writers who could go and
create their own brands but news is
still news and you trust the news to be
there
i think when you start to see those
trends move over then things could
become a little interesting
um i do i do want to see
um how uh how platforms
like sub stack or you know other kind of
or like ghost or mailchimp start to
build on top of that comfort confidence
level like that's me is my passion
economy
thesis like how i think about you know
investing how i think about
uh products being built it's all around
this idea of like enabling that creator
comfort and confidence
and once those things start to pick up i
think we'll start to see gradually other
things move over
and it'll start to kind of like boom up
and move
um there's like this idea of membership
which i think
this uh this which which we didn't hit
on but it's a big point
um the idea of subscriptions is very
transactional and old right it's kind of
like
i pay you to get content and it's like
like i give you the ticket you give me
the goods i'm out membership is really
like
about status identity it's like amazon
prime
i have two day shipping i have whole
foods discounts it's my identity it's my
status i need that
um these independent creators are
building similar things right like
like webb smith has polymathic you can
join to be a part of that community
you engage on that particular community
there's like
monthly webinars there's a lot of um
uh people are doing like like community
only
conversations you can have like
one-to-one interviews like
it goes way beyond access and into these
benefits and as those things start to
build
that's gonna pose a real threat to you
know traditional media companies or any
businesses that are just focused on
subscription when it's like well i'm
paying you and all i get is this content
i'm paying this creator and i'm getting
50 things a month right and i'm really
kind of part of this
uh community and it it like essentially
becomes my identity
the last thing to put on my crypto hat
which i'm begging for
is like this ownership economy right so
so like how do you
start to be able to build a platform
where your audience
right like your loyal audience the ones
who follow you the ones who engage
are actually equitable like in you as a
brand right instead of
instead of um creators getting like
paid through transactional subscriptions
or by media companies
what does it look like when the
community itself start to like engage
with the creators on a level where they
then have a stake in the ip they then
have a stake in your
success very crypto thinking but like
been hammering that for a bit and
waiting and waiting and waiting for that
to start to move and people are thinking
that way right and it's
that's where i think things start to
become really interesting because it's
like
i believe in you as a creator so much so
that i have equity in you
as a creator you create this content
there's benefits for me
but then if you as a creator end up
getting bought like you joe rogan
get this deal or go somewhere else then
there starts to become returns to that
community and that
really is kind of like sparks a new
economy that's really weird but
really exciting look we're already
seeing it in some form or fashion with
like the lambda school
isas or i think i'm sharing agreements
and things like that now that's a very
uh specific use case with kind of capped
risk for
both the individual and for lambda and
so i think that's kind of a test the
waters dip your toe
uh type thing but to your point is there
a world where creator in the future says
hey
i'm basically gonna put myself on
kickstarter right you're gonna give me
some money up front i'm gonna go create
awesome content
and every dollar i make you're gonna get
you know as a community 20 cents of
uh and i'm gonna do this and i commit to
doing it for the next five years
right or you know whatever it is you
could see people
very very much saying yeah this is worth
it and then if all of a sudden
uh kind of your share in the creator is
tradable right so hey we thought that
you know they were going to make 100k a
year but next year they're making 250.
i've been able to pull out all the value
i want out of this now i can actually
sell the
uh the share of the token at a higher
price i mean you can see this whole
thing really yeah
yeah it creates it like creates an
entirely new world that i think is
i think it's something people have been
asking for and people want like
you see these this like i kind of said
this earlier like i feel
i feel even with newsletter
subscriptions that i pay for
that it's less about me paying for that
content because i need that content even
though i wouldn't subscribe if it wasn't
valuable
but it's more so i feel like i am
investing in that creator knowing that
they they need this money in order to
continue creating the content i like and
building the community i like
um if there's an option to say okay you
can pay ten dollars a month for this
newsletter or you could pay 20
a month right and you accrue 0.05
percent of
like holdings of this like of this
company then maybe i would do that
because my
kind of intent to subscribing in the
first place is to
invest in this creator and believe that
this creator is kind of going places so
yeah i love it it makes a makes a ton of
sense
where um where can people find you on
the internet and where do we want to
send them
yeah so i'm at jared dicker on twitter
that's where i've been spending way too
much time
lately um so shoot me a note there i get
back to everybody so
would love to chat you are uh one of my
favorite follows because i feel like
you're willing to uh to say the things
that
are unlikely to happen but two may be
unpopular
or people don't understand so please
keep going because uh
you make me think all the time when you
tweet stuff but i appreciate you coming
on and we're gonna have to do
we'll do round three again at some point
in the future fantastic thanks for
having me it's blast